[Music]
[Applause]
it is raining a little bit but I like
you guys so much that I'm gonna persist
and we're gonna talk more about
butterflies we're gonna take a bit of it
because I want you have a lot of control
and I mean a lot of people it's a move
where people will kind of learn it but
they're kind of hacking it which means
if you kind of do the move but they
don't fully get it and so it's never
very elegant and I want you to fully
understand it so that you can do all the
cool variations and what we're gonna do
is this go forwards same time on your
wheel planes and you're just gonna slow
the in difficulty or mirror me so there
should be your right hand make it a
little bit higher and you're gonna
slowly bend your planes in and try to go
really slow with the POI
and see how it's the poi start to
overlap your right poise falling down on
top of the left poi and you can control
me me to start further apart and then
make the difference more more subtle and
slowly slowly slowly bend it you know
what a lot of people do is they go yeah
and they want to jump over all that
awkwardness but this is you know that's
it kind of like I'm sure it feels off
the life lesson in here of instead of
jumping over the awkwardness confront it
because that's where the power is gonna
come from in the end and again guys you
might want to put one leg friendly other
and what's gonna happen is there's
something really important to understand
in letting them over lap until you get
all the way to butterfly and then slowly
slowly slowly slowly slowly back then
put the other hand on top again it's
really because this your body's kind of
wanting to do its you know as soon as it
any of that fear comes in all the spicy
stuff happens and you want to breathe
through that so okay spicy stuff they go
no I want to
ah and if you do that you're gonna know
you're gonna understand on a really
visceral level really what's going on
you go oh I see it's there
I see fun okay and then when you start
getting all this stuff it's gonna make
it any longer a lot users start doing
all the tricks if you get it right so
right hand on top mmm coming slowly left
hand on top comes though yeah no I mean
you can vary the rhythm of London and of
course also everything starting
backwards says you come in if your right
hands on top the left hand will be
chasing it up and so now the left hand
is lower so it's coming up on the bottom
or the right hand is lower it's coming
up on the bottom and again see her
breathe go slow go slow as you can and
then you can actually see really what's
going on until you can get it right into
a butterfly it slowly bend back and
again if you're making little circles
with the fingers and wrists that's
that's where a lot of your control in
the planes is going to come from so in
the long run we're going to talk about
how you can do all this in turn so this
is inwards and outwards and threading
the needle and around behind the head
and both and all of that and if you can
just do this with me to where you're
bending them in and understanding it all
of that is gonna roll smoothly we're
gonna learn it all you're gonna do fine
you're gonna do great this stuff I like
teaching this stuff because it goes
pretty pretty well so play with that and
yeah I don't if you get stuck make a
video I like it we make videos we make
videos and video responses of course
gets better for everybody
[Music]